はぁ
[音楽]
たった今日は特に必要です結構最近ねっかで話題になっている
超辛い組ご存知でしょうか何人かのユーチューバーはもう動画にしてるんですけども
こちらで切るニトロなって分かな
the work for てすぐ隠蔽世界で一番辛い杭らしいですもうこのたび本
ドバッチックとかわいらしくても僕はこれ見ただけでも競技で小野
オンロードろーいておりますよで私考えました今だおいしい美味しくはないですよ今で
買い物ただくってももったいないということでちょっと楽しみだから食べればいいなと
思いますって私は思いましたグミベアクマの形をしたグミといえば
haribo グミですね杏ちゃん見分けつかないんじゃないかと思いますしてあげて
みますね
まずコツ挙げてみますやばいよく身一つにこんなことあるても毛頭見てもはぎ坊栗だと
思うんですよね
あっ haribo グミの比較してみましょう
[音楽]
さあ
変えろとか出してみますの見てこれってほぼ一緒じゃないですかねぇ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーバーした相棒組のや[ __ ]交ですっ
世界力組を3つ準備しました
いやーハロえっまたってても湧かないと思うんですけど着れますね
[ __ ]ってきてみればそれもわからないけど一緒にいる時もはいもう完全にわからない
と思いますこんな恐ろしい版を使って今回何でしょうかといいますと
ハリボーグ2戦通算子だけが衝撃から組なんて
ただいま
からここへ来たり音出てきそうなゲームをやってるこれをたくさん食べよう的なことを
適当にいってまぁ運が悪かったら多分1000分の3の確率でデッキから軍を引いて
しまうという
気付い中でくるペリーはとっても美味しいグミ食べる動画なってると思うんねはたして
どんなゲーム輸送から買ったらどんな反応するめっ上下早速やっていきましょう
病院の今日もやってまいりました
アメリカで大旅行ハリボーイシャル ger
ああああああ
アメリカって言った入ってますって裏俺たちだ絶対チャレンジ成功できると思うんで
まぁあんまってニャー
なんだったルールでプレイなんですけどねじゃんけんで誰一人負けを決めると負けた人
か
磨くしてごっそり食べるねこっそいそーいや自分で取る
どうぞあろう
それでなんかこういうふうにへ
あの
美味しかったら弾ませがんばれ
0富士られないこれセンターですよいう本当にはサインテラスてうーん勝てば食わなく
ていいから
うーんそれどんだけくるか手帳する者1人333おけばいいだけですああ
いっぱいで終わりますこれ
nara
はいお知らせじゃんけんぽんっ
おっしゃいがんばらざるだー一緒で行くぞ
goo
変革やするんだよ
はいどうぞどうよこれれるですよってかなきゃいけんからねじゃあ
言いますねはいじゃあ
をいや俺うわぁウール
わー最初はれるだけ本再生けっけっぽい
あいこでしょ内科ですよこれ hey
me
ね
はっはっはっ打って上げずに持った感じは買ったんですけど
japan
萌えてるぞいきます誰か j
うーんああなんかのすてっかーんところあるというか浮いちゃってます
どうでしょうかね
んだよああいいですうん良い
danner
ん
[音楽]
[拍手]
voodoo
区薬院どんどんノートペンこっだうわーもう1回出て箱の中にでっかい辛い組が3個
入ってます
あああああじゃなくたら入ったらもうこれだしてるって言うとそういうことをよく弾い
た音でも結構組んだけど全部の判断
俺負けで終わらないですかでなくなったら終わりしますよなぁ
んはぁっ本当は接触10本1本
そう処暑言い合って
私はぐっだけ今じゃさああああ
実現したら聞きたい市場ではあんまに行きますよおおーー
なぜないとねはい
グッ
1回鳴らしましたイェイ
ますはいはーい
[音楽]
8 ao
がは順当にねますどうぞ最初はグーじゃんけんぽん所
そういやあ
いるはおかしくないですかどうりでも iphone と言われそう見える min
食べないと思えほんとでこうよねよまじで食ってほしいよって作ったんですよね
どこ
売ってないんか下のほうがいいじゃないですか
もうこっちは勝って黒いです
うわぁ
動いんベンチャーグッズやっぱ
やりますテンプレぐっぴょん
ちょっとあまりに目指すすぎるんでちょっと減らせますさあちょっと箱を減らして確率
を絞りましたどんな次元らっしゃい対照群と日本
ショップっしょいまずタイム
ねはいはい
[音楽]
中もこれ着てますか p クリスマスいますあっはぁ
バッハからこれは館でバンズに国という話があるため言ってスカイいるから探したり
そこで済んだと思っていると思う
いたあと1匹あと1匹まだいますまでいますたい初級者ポンチョ
#車一波か分からん
ファットミスターで見聞した感じませんをナイスプレー
せっかく送ってポンっじゃあ
プードゥル安定この確率はもうアタリを待つ
さすがに携帯してきましたはい
増えたんでしょはいこっちからこっちかで行くんでしょそうそう硬直ついて
ここでフュージョンおおぉおおっ
大乗上げ者兼バージョンっ
par
ほえっ弾ご覧くださいこんな少ないもやばいや確率
30分の1ぐらいなってしまいました私はじゃんけんぽんっ
コアなのよはい
karan ブーブーポンプ毛根ヌー
右ん
ねえんだけどいよいよラストです
皆さん
うっはっはー
もう前ぜ僕本文多いまでまあまあ動く恋
あれっよあれ固めちゃっやっへっ
うんなんか走ってるのもギャーッ
ben 声を良いん
た
はーい
tao
pa
me
ni
[音楽]
bejean